on stage dancer Manuel in the
unconscious of a unique flamenco dream
world taking the audience on a journey
into his subconscious
[Music]
his brilliant technique and experimental
star let him go wherever his imagination
takes him he choreographed his own show
called by a leader I'll tour for the
headers flamenco festival
[Music]
was so yummy smoke is the author that me
and me is an imaginary individual living
in a fantasy world when I create
something new I'm like a child living
out my fantasy I've got this curiosity
and this childlike innocence so my show
channels this childlike creativity and
fantasy a matinee on his show boldly
challenges conventions questioning
gender roles it's a deliberate
provocation in the mature world of
flamenco it's earned him the respect of
critics and audiences alike man when
Linnaean is regarded as one of the
world's greatest flamenco dancers
[Music]
la première karate video I don't view
the awards I've won since starting to
perform in dresses as praise for my own
accomplishments instead they acknowledge
that everyone should express themselves
and dance however they want Buddha
mailari puede pasar se como Kiara
praises the animal today's flamenco
festival has a diverse program the dance
originated in the region of Andalusia
and is deeply influenced by Roma culture
typical flamenco clothing also has a
Roma Flair it flatters the figure and
features lots of flounces shops selling
the traditional garments are popular
when the festival is on this year rich
reds and purples are a
a la moda flamenco styles change every
year some designs resemble each other
Tomiko costumes are traditional but they
change more than any other type of
traditional Spanish clothing a dress
like this can cost several hundred euros
for Andalusian women flamenco dresses
are what the little black dress is to
others
I've had about 30 dresses in my life
it's the same for my mother and she gave
some to me even when I was small I got
to put on the dresses and I'll pass them
on to my children people from all over
the world come to the festival workshops
with famous artists like Mercedes Louise
are quickly booked up lots of dancers
have come especially from Asia many are
there for the long haul taking courses
during the day going to concerts at
night and living an illusion style
flamenco pure and simple otherwise
likely you only have one feeling always
happy but family who have different
fellows different feelings
so it's express every day when you dance
flamingo is different it's even it's the
same music but depends on the feeling
when dance I think this is just who I am
and no matter good or not this is who I
am
and my characters are midnight
performances in the bodegas of Tears are
particularly popular the concert mujeres
de la Frontera is a homage to the women
it's the classical side of flamenco
[Music]
del flamenco soon article menko is a
living culture it just continues to
evolve as it should the traditional form
of flamenco should progress too but
there are artists who are fighting for
real advances we want to express what
moves them right now ok good god I will
know whether Denis and it's this
cultural diversity that makes the fairs
festivals so special
[Music]
you
[Applause]